he's Dennis Scott here on the Rich Eisen
show how you doing Dennis rich it's a
pleasure to be on here some long time so
excited Terry what's how you my friend I
am doing I am doing great cuz I look I
remember I don't remember the last time
you spoke but I remember covering you
and I remember Stewart loving you
because you had the same last name I
remember him loving you know calling
your highlights when your shooting
threes because you had the same last
name and you know so I obviously have
been thinking about you for a long time
essentially covered and since then I've
been watching you remember I'm a huge
NFL fan so watching through an NFL
Network of do enjoy all your stuff I'm
super excited for you as well so what's
your team in the NFL Dallas Cowboys
among some diehard and one of those guys
who were born and raised in the DMV but
I didn't like the rare skin so I'm a
die-hard cowboy fans yes we are
rebuilding right don't inoculate
yourself from the cowboy struggles by
just admitting them straight out so why
why can't I mean why don't you go
Redskins then Dennis well I just think
as a kid when you growing up in the you
know 70s early 80s you had to take a pic
of you know wearing are no good be a
Hulk or seeing you know having
personality and having some Flair so my
personality gravitated more to the
Cowboys and my older brother gravitated
to the risky ins that's probably two
times we don't speak here and now you
know Witten having left the Cowboys to
go to the booth what's been your
challenge I guess that you've been able
to handle so so well to go from playing
to talking about it to listen at the
biggest I guess challenge is letting the
guys know my peers
know that I'm gonna be honest and I know
exactly what you're going through on a
daily basis I'm not the beat writer I'm
not coming to find the story or what you
and your wife did or how many kids there
well how many cars you have I don't let
other people worry about that I'm trying
to find a big potatoes to let the people
know why you're so good at what you do
or tell people under
why they're struggling right now all for
instant people always calling me now
about Benson I've already spoke with Ben
a lot I spoke with his agent Liz Paul
there will be a time where he and I will
try to get together and work on his shot
but you don't look like you're shot in
the middle of the playoffs you keep
playing your game and in the office to
work on things of that nature
well I mean is that what he you thought
he struggled the other night with his
famed 1 point performance it he was
thinking too much is that what you're
saying Dennis look no question about it
it's when when guy like Donovan Mitchell
he's so transparent and honest when he
struggled other night
he admitted I was thank you too much I
mean they play my game his game was
attacking scoop layup shoot threes now
Ben Simmons what made you the number one
pick attacking you're running one hand
shots playing your game you worry about
the things you cannot do when he all
sees not in the playoffs Dennis Scott
here in the Rich Eisen show what's the
fix for the Raptors other than just
getting LeBron to retire but that's
what's the fix it if I'm inside you do I
know he's going on a long boat ride cuz
that's a tough decision because that is
until the Brian and I was probably one
of your questions until a blonde makes a
decision if he's leaving the Eastern
Conference going to the West then if he
leaves maybe keep the team the way it is
because now you're facing a healthy
Boston next year a more improved more
experienced Philadelphia team or do you
say DeMar DeRozan and Lowry you've been
together long enough it's time to pick
you guys up and trade somebody you know
you and you bring up LeBron there Dennis
so you know I receive a little bit of
criticism that I see anytime I talk
about it on this show from the
Twitterverse which happens that that you
know that that's an that's another time
that's July 1st that right now there's
something going on and for anybody to
bring up the decision that he's gonna
have to make in a couple of months is
just stirring up the pot all that said
why in the world would LeBron go to the
Western Conference
well and why would he go to then all
honesty to a Lakers team where he's just
one of many goats he's now in the goat
pasture
where that that that's how he would have
to be measured by unless he wants to go
to the Clippers where that would be a
completely new piece of ground that he
could build up like he did for the land
and away in Cleveland on something rich
you're in touching on some know
everything you just said you're right on
point if I was a blonde and for your
listeners the Clippers make more sense
than anything because now you're sitting
down you're saying yourself I'm teaming
up with Jerry West and local one of the
brightest minds ever in basketball far
as historical you know putting the team
together
that's not for did Jerry West was part
of the brain trust that helped turn
around the goes big waters contract runs
out then he goes to the Clippers because
he and Ballmer on the same page now
so now Jerry West is helping bomber make
better basketball toises is known back
on Doc Rivers we all loved Doc Rivers
but bomber said doctor has done what
he's done let me go get one of the best
minds ever in the game it helped me get
to this next level which is trying to
win a championship so Bob LeBron James
and I'm sitting down with Jerry West and
Palmer Palmer can help my business side
of my brand because he is a
multi-billionaire Jerry West can help me
get more rings in the day I'm all about
when it ring is not just making a
playoff so as we sail all that rich
which one of those teams which best
young talent is LeBron the best chance
to win I think that's what I would make
a decision well I think that that's
obviously the Lakers as it currently
stands or even Philadelphia and he
should stay in the East I mean just stay
there but that risk if you read social
media today mmm if Kawhi Leonard is
definitely leaving the Spurs and going
to the Lakers or clippers or somewhere
in the Western Conference and then a
good friend of mine you know yes yeah
kind of beat me to the punch
I think there's my good friend Bryan
winters there hey don't be surprised if
you see LeBron equai Leonard
connected together versus LeBron and
Paul George didn't apply really thick
and rich well San Antonio would have to
be somewhat compliant in that I imagine
what Ingram has to give up all you have
to give up some of those young pieces
and drastic for it to make sense so now
LeBron going through a legacy fair oh
and while we're sweating little baby
while we're spitting truth Denis before
I let you go what what what is your take
on Kawhi Leonard what in the world is
happening over there I mean he appears
to be the only player again that that is
told Popovich I'm tired of this as
opposed to something else that I unless
I'm reading something in that hasn't
obviously been said publicly what do you
think is going on there you hear around
here for Kawhi Leonard to be this young
superstar that he did not have that
outgoing sharing personality hi feels
this very different in artists young NBA
and young sports today for that matter
and we've never seen anyone bucked the
system of the Spurs especially on the
superstar level so with that being said
if you listen to some of the brand
people's fans at hey you know brand
Jordan's last Nike once in somewhere
else if he wants that $200 shoe deal
that we see that know the heart and the
ranch and the Steph Curry's have gotten
recently or even Thomas got a big Nike
deal that's the new talk on the street
that another reason why he wants out so
with all that being said I'm still
shocked if I had to bet on it I don't
know if I'm think I don't think I'm a
seed Kawhi Leonard the Spurs uniform
next year Wow
last one for you Dennis Scott what
happens when Houston plays Golden State
in the seven game coming up I'm gonna be
jealous i'ma go call my mom and say mom
you happy too early because of shooting
too many threes I'm hosting plan in the
series and then when it's all said and
done who wins it I think
I think the warrior toughness and ball
movement will be the difference how many
was threes would you have average how
many how many threes would you have
averaged
you're in today's again in your prime if
you're in your prime in today's game how
many threes in my prime so the Year in
96 not broke the record I was taking I
had a guy for NBA TV looking up I was
taking nine and a half threes a game fan
so now if you're in the if you're in the
warrior system or if you're in a rocket
system today that's at least I'm at
least taking 15 threes a game making
eight or nine a game oh my goodness you
makes my hands wit rich would you have
taken any two-point shots any two-point
shots you do just be a rocket no way
unless it's a decoy layup or something
weird having the rocket system I could
never see myself taking a clue
Dennis love the chat let's do it again
down the line here in the playoffs it's
been way too long
okay way too long anything about it you
got it right back at you that's Dennis
Scott Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience